we're actually still waiting on someone
so this kind of awkward what we will do
is jump right in and go to the first
click on our thing and hopefully by that
point uh no no no let's let roll it roll
it integrates lives tops versus Angela
hahaha excellent
we don't have pronounce it
um so that is the worst fighting game of
all time um okay she's not here I I had
a plan was gonna be really impressive
although introductions now I'm Luke
Lancaster with cnet oh hi I'm Nikki li
Xing it i'm david hollingworth on it all
the philly I didn't see there ah and I'm
Jane crowd i'm from gamespot um and we
all play a lot of Star Wars games and
much love Star Wars and talk about a lot
of Star Wars green stuff and leave star
was in my day-to-day life really I'm not
happy i don't want to tell you how it's
too embarrassing how to live star wars
you've got let's get our bathrobes don't
hear ya know I actually do actually do
um yeah it's embarrassing okay um also
the empty seat is a lot of pace from IGN
who is gonna be really really
embarrassed when she 30 so you've really
important when she comes up please do
make it a big deal why a star wars game
so bad you know that's the age-old
question really um is there is there a
simple answer see that's i deferred it
away yeah i was good that is very simple
and cynically yes there is star wars
isn't very good to begin with so the
games we're never gonna be great
take him down why did I ask you to be on
the channel thanks to Lily too hilly
thank you for noticing um I think often
because so I grew up with with Star Wars
you know I saw it when I was six years
old in the cinema um so it is this very
very personal thing and you go star wars
game that can't suck so that's one of
the reasons look I think we also
certainly people David my age generation
we got used two games being bad like
games just were especially if they were
going to be a tie into a film or a
franchise I mean I actually played the
poltergeist game on Atari and it did not
have a lot to do with the film I can
assure you of that and was not very good
I think we just expected that a game
that was gonna be a license thing like
that was going to be bad that's really
true I don't think there are any
licensed games anymore other that aren't
mobile games does anyone mate is it been
a console licensed game like Legos and
tire model that's true but does that
count that's kind of two properties does
that really count as like it's just over
two things it's fine yeah that's great i
cant Alita Graham's actually pretty good
yeah so I think it's just stuff like
terrace car see you get games that you
don't need a Star Wars fighting game it
doesn't make sense that storm troopers
who just are there to get shot our
martial artists right but were they all
that you haven't moved where what is han
Solo known for drawing his gun but there
is a move in that video where he puts it
away that's so you can keep taking it
out right no it was bad and like you
want these games to be good right we all
love Star Wars probably too okay apart
from Nick Nick doesn't here we go
this terms aren't gonna raid themselves
hi everyone I'm a lot I guess is the
part where we have already introduced
ourselves Olivia okay I'm an editor at
IGN and I'm really hoping that
battlefront two is good Oh should we
talk about battle want one now no not
yet not yet already in no n-not you soon
the wounds are still too fresh crab ok
but like I think this goes back to the
original sort of like super star wars
games cuz I replayed those in
preparation of this panel that's right I
do research and they're not good guys
which is a controversial opinion I'm
gonna throw it to the audience Super
Star Wars good or bad have you played
them recently yeah I'm wrong sorry what
if he's wrong yeah what makes it bad in
your eyes yes they'll way too hard I've
all go on the record and say that they
are way too hard but that's all games
but we all know game show music video
game yeah that's true no it's the
children to Rome um I I replayed Super
Star Wars again recently and I think
it's got this rose colored glasses of my
youth playing it in my lounge room you
know on my CIT while my parents are
asleep upstairs and I'm turning it down
and like as an adult I don't have that
connection to it anymore and I'm just
like I don't have the time to play this
anymore I just can't be bothered when I
was a kid I could sit there and play it
and just like struggle through the harsh
difficulty like you said but now man I
value my time too much I wouldn't might
rather be a slave like oh love having a
now I'm gonna sleep that's true that is
all we had back then like these bad
games were all we could play and I
remember tricking myself I got masses of
teras kasi does anyone know how to
pronounce it is a terrace casa de terras
kasai teras kasi let's go with terrace
car seat I uh it was the first game I
convinced my mom to buy me not for my
birthday or Christmas we were at meijer
and I played it on a our honor on a
console
like demo station and I played that
level the one on Endor and I was like oh
my god this is amazing this is the best
game ever made mum buy this for me she
was like all right cool this is this is
out of the ordinary you can have it I
remember getting at home playing it a
little bit and just realizing how [ __ ]
it was and just convincing myself that
it wasn't issued game I used to get
friends around to trick them be like hey
man this is a really good game but we
all knew it was just so bad Rose tinted
glasses and video games is kind of a
fascinating thing and I think that
there's actually this period of time
where you can pinpoint your nostalgia
and I think it's from an age where you
can remember everything but you haven't
fully developed critical thinking so I
think it's like if it's not even a joke
i think it's like up to the point where
you hit about 13 you wanna stahl [ __ ]
from everything from like maybe nine to
thirteen and for a lot of people that
also encompass is star wars because i
feel like it's family-friendly it's a
family fantasy series and it's something
that people see it a really young age
and then we just like to pretend that
all of the games are good same thing
happened when the prequels came out and
everyone was like oh it's good what I
did it's car no one ever saw don't show
of hands who didn't hate the first
prequel until they'd seen it at least
twice me for sure is it because you
wanted to believe that's exactly what I
wanted to believe yeah that would have
helped but we're talking about podracer
Palmer's there was the episode 1 tie in
Game puddle oh okay good yeah yeah yeah
they really is him well um I don't
absolutely hated pot right so but I was
playing it on PC dan was saying before
that on on n64 that wasn't that was one
of the best n64 games ever made and that
was that cheat code where you could get
2 n64 controllers and control the
engines ah independently we knew it was
you don't know well I didn't know oh my
god when I found that out it's also did
you know on time crisis on ps1 if you
put a controller on the floor and had
the gun con you could step on the
controller and use it as pedal anyone
else know that well that's breaking down
when they just do dumb [ __ ] like that I
think that's brilliant but yeah like a
whole dresser on the n64 was just again
I think it was my child
getting friends around we play full
place for its split screen and just know
I don't really have really good memories
my friends with a zero yes they also
didn't exist that was open I thought
someone um speaking of games from our
youth that we have a real nostalgic tie
to play Jedi Knight to recently David no
I have such a deep affection for that
game because I came is the thing that
taught me how to use console codes right
because you don't want to go at the
start you want to be a Jedi you want
your life saver um don't play through it
again if you have any fun memories of
that game do not play it again and it
might just be us getting older but like
I still have Star Wars I still have the
original movies yeah i still love dark
forces i think is one of the greatest
games ever i can't go back and play it
ever again yeah so my theory is that
star wars games can be good if they're
not tied in to a film so I still say
that coat or is just what the best
things ever to was great you get away
from what the franchise has done
cinematically and you can have a great
game I'm gonna slow down a bit further
from possibly i was gonna say except for
the sound design like the one thing that
I love about battlefront is the sound
design if you rip that straight from the
film's stoked but like it's almost
perfect because they actually you know
you it sounds like Star Wars because it
is Star Wars what is the greatest things
about that game how it sounds yes yeah
and then there's the rest yes hey it
looks alright it's prettier than 20
minutes of gameplay that's true that
first 20 minutes you always have it's
one of those games that if you play it
at a convention and you play with a lot
of people it's super fun and then you
play it in your living room by yourself
you like that deal see ya I really pay
for that season pass a while ago um
we're just talking about kotor and games
that aren't directly tied into the main
star wars canon Oh talk is a very good
by away again Bob I witchy but isn't a
good star wars game like star wars game
I didn't say it's not a star wars game
but you said it was a good buy away
again what do you think of bioware games
in general I'm a fan of bioware games in
general like I think bioware make really
good games but the thing I look for in
Star Wars is that
the feeling of the world the very black
and white moral certitude lightsaber
noises you know and I'll own up to that
um and I don't think by we're suited to
making that kind of game I'm gonna have
to level with everyone in this room ah
I've never played kotor well um I know
and I know and I know I've waited I
waited too long because now when I try
to play it it hasn't aged the best so as
someone who's never played it has no
connection to it I just can't get into
it hey I've tried multiple times on like
multiple consoles and like on my phone
on my iPad on my computer and I just
it's about yeah it's on everything
literally everything on phone oh pretty
well pretty well looks great yeah yeah
don't like one of the big app store
releases when it came out of room was
like oh travel and you know I don't
caught up in the hype and then I was on
the train and I was like just crying a
little bit I don't want this sleeping on
this room 116 done yeah yeah where's my
1699 um alright clip2 um we got to talk
about the prequels because it is the bad
thing in Star Wars like the number one
bad thing and I will go so far as to say
apart from podracer every game about the
prequels is bad mmm-hmm that's correct
this one is really bad
okay so um I'm a video producer for
gamespot and that was one of the worst
edited things I've ever seen oh my god
why would it so long my favorite thing
about it is that is like all the combat
in the game like was not more than that
why keep what was it doing front flips I
don't that's the prequels that's dead on
everyone front flips they do I don't
remember the Xbox looking that garbage
so I just looked it up on metascore uh
it'sit's metascore Metacritic is a 58
but I particularly like that the number
one of you is 88 it's like well this
program might not be as intense as halo
this program what does any of that mean
yahoo says just plain fun thanks yahoo
now seven out of 10 I mean watching that
I got memories of shadows of the empire
on n64 and everyone has fond memories of
like the hoff level in shadows of the
empire but the rest of it is hot garbage
that game sucks it has like really weird
platforming pops yeah that because you
have to be so precise because the game
sucks is nearly impossible yeah it
wasn't fun yeah shadows is weird because
part of this this larger attempt by
Lucasfilm and lucasarts to create this
whole new property new characters new
setting new designs and it was like wow
this is just the time for a tired for
tired and there was no actual original
property it was just all commercial all
these games kind of came out in a time
when they were just throwing so many
Star Wars things at the wall to see what
would stick and I think that's probably
what led to this like bad star wars game
she just tried everything I think part
of it has to also be working with Lucas
I don't know if this has been the same
way the whole time but I went to Disney
infinity to Avalanche before they shut
down and there were so many things that
they asked us to cut in the video we
were making about how they produce
Disney infinity toys because they were
like working with Disney sucks and they
kind of refer to things as being handed
to you on the Mickey gloves so they're
like really smiley about it but they're
trying to design kylo Ren and they only
get to see like one shot they used fan
on that other people had made to try to
make Tyler
ran as a thicker like it seems like
walking with Lucas kind of makes things
hot who you yeah nobody guessed I mean
speaking of working with Lucas and by
Lucas now I mean George Lucas this is
something I love about the EU it's
hundreds of people trying to explain the
[ __ ] that he just makes up that
looks cool yeah so do you know the
origin of Jar Jar Binks his voice so on
set via motion capture artist just did a
dopey voice and George Lucas was like
brilliant lobby we're gonna use it and
he was like what what what and then no
one said hey George that's a battle yeah
right like that's how it that's how he
made decisions one of my favorite
stories about the prequels is that when
he was deciding what would be CG and
what would be a physical or practical
effect they basically had this board of
scenes and characters and he just took a
highlighter and was like the ones that a
yellow will be CG and the ones that are
orange will be practical effects and
just was whining just anything he could
find just completely no preparation and
everyone in the rooms just screaming
there's one that he accidentally lined
in the wrong color and like went over it
with yellow and was like oh it's close
enough to yellow and everyone's just
panicking while he's making these
decisions that basically ultimately
ended up in everything looking terrible
a friend of mine actually worked on one
of the prequels she's a slime or is the
character's name it's like the Emperor's
personal assistant she pees in about two
seconds despite having been on set for
like three months or something
ridiculous like that even had her own
action figure like scared out to be made
up for her how long is her will keep EDA
entry I bet it's huge I have actually
checked it out yet it's not even our
different to all of the figures that we
got of what's what's her name the chrome
lady uh-uh Ozma phasma we got so many
figures of phasma and then she has such
a small role in the force awakens and
it's like I don't know if they plan to
have her in those films more and then
took it out and we had no ray figures
for whatever reason like they were
really strange with toys and its toys
that effectively funded the prequels
they moon star wars toys they also
completely changed the market for action
figures and it's absolutely amazing like
that until my Seng changed with you yeah
they're like articulation is different
like Hasbro basically became a company
because of the way that Star Wars
figures came to life and it's them it's
really strange
decision making with the ones they
choose to release yes don't understand
yeah that's tons of you you could you
could argue that that's the major
problem of force awakens is they're
attempting to recapture all the stuff
that worked from the original trilogy
and that's why I think phasma is only in
it for a little bit they were like she's
gonna be the Boba Fett we got a we got
Starkiller base that's a test yeah we
got x-wings but they're a little bit
different the blasters in there a little
bit different like I played it safe and
I'm hoping with the next movies they
later hey reb one looks very different
so see how that goes okay who has played
the Gungan frontier you're a brave man
well I don't know one guys how is this
the building on it is a sim strategy
game where you need to colonize a moon
so the Gungans can live there and I hope
problem with this conceptually now that
sounds great a good they were kicked off
in a booth they were like get out we
don't want you anymore I got a woman
yeah just leave just go you like
defended the planet at the end of like
episode 1 but you're real annoying get
out yeah something like that anyway I
don't want to play a game where my role
is to keep Gungans alive right oh but
that's really annoying and also all of
the other Gungans I'm sorry
could we just do a quick for all who
heads all Gungans but listen East Raja
is a Sith I told you it was a real
theory I told you I believed you it's
just silly heaven forbid star would be
silly yeah so you you played this game
no Google injury you didn't because
you're racist racist racist racist it's
a different thing it's a different thing
space is too perfect I'm spaces um but
there's this whole slew of the proper
what you think of when you say a
licensed game words like its a math game
with Jabbar real thing it's Yoda stories
which stays awful see we had Yoda
stories installed on our primary school
computers and so as growing up as a
heavy child that was where I spent most
of my life roads um was on the on the
school on our classroom computer leading
him around all da is it today but it is
Dagobah right first date yeah yeah why
you can't run take about oh yes you're
this isn't the math adventure this is
yoda's procedural chore help hmm
basically oddly I want to play that
masochist yeah and you won't replay dark
forces yeah okay okay let's talk about
it now I'm v8 430
it is unavoidable we will witness the
destruction of the Alliance
aimed at this insignificant billion
soldiers of the Rebel Alliance there's
animals
are our only hope [ __ ] is your attack on
the Walker
in my way
that won't happen again from reaching
the face
you
your victory will be short-lived
you
that's my turn
the hall we're not
yeah pathetic rebellion yeah
so that trailer is so good it makes me
want to play battlefront again I was
getting chills with the beginning it's
so good and like when our that rebel
pilot looks at the at the Millennium
Falcon you like that's that's me that's
me Oh like it's so good I don't even
care about the slightly more voices all
right no pretty jarring you've got it
yeah yeah all the fact that Palpatine
was never on the forest moon of Endor
I'm just pointing it out I don't know
I'm gonna be knocked down then from
shore Sanders on our a nice to be like
let's paint that wall gray um that one
is a 73 on med school and he's a score
of 5 well that's out of out of 100 yes 1
105 point oh okay that got a slightly
better um what went wrong with
Battlefront I think it's boring designed
for children that's that's interesting
um yeah it i will agree with that i
think i think heroes i play star wars
games not to play as a Jedi I don't like
playing as a Jedi they're boring Jedi's
are too powerful it's like playing
Superman don't want to do it I want to
play as a smuggler or I want to play as
a rebel I want to play is like a lowly
nothing person who's in this massive
universe and have my own adventure and
when I run around the battle at the
battlefield I guess cuz dice make that
too um I like I want to feel like I'm
part of something bigger I don't want to
be like the the winning to be able to
turn the tide I want to like be able to
be part of something bigger like part of
like the galactic war that's what I want
and yeah I don't know you're saying you
want single player well there's my
battlefield one so if they took the
campaign from battlefield one and
literally just put star wars [ __ ] in it
and had you going around the galaxy my
god it would be amazing I totally agree
I i would bet money that battlefield two
will have a single player campaign
definitely definitely it wouldn't be
hard for them to do the same thing the
battlefield one didn't do it effectively
to exactly when it's yeah that would be
really cool and then you can do like any
time period and you can do all kinds of
cool [ __ ] and also like I know everyone
hates
wrinkles but the prequels had some great
designing them like the Naboo
starfighters stuff like that I wanted
that I don't want to just like bum
around in an x-wing and a freakin a wing
I'm so bored like up talking what you
don't like me to boost our fighters I'm
saying stop talking [ __ ] about x-wings
but also yes no I love an expert I love
a good x-wing this big right but come on
I want I want I want some change I don't
want you know walk is on every planet I
want something that's that's unique to
each planet stuff like that so the
reason I like Star Wars and I guess most
people do is because I like weird as
[ __ ] aliens sorry yeah I just like very
very strange things existing and I think
stall was does a very good job of not
giving you too much exposition it's like
this is a thing that exists this is what
it does I'm not gonna tell you anything
else figure it out and I love that and I
love how well stall was does bad in a
multiplayer only game you don't get any
of that they could have even put Lauren
to the multiplayer maybe but they didn't
but this I feel like this isn't
productive how how would they make what
could they have done the gameplay wise
to make you guys like battlefront more
um this is outside of single player it
sounds like a really lame thing but aim
down sights aim down sights think the
maps just a little bit smaller I think
it's agree to it came from its dice and
you think dice doing star wars
battlefront it's given like battlefield
with a deal 44 and it wasn't it was just
liked yeah it almost felt like they done
the first pass and they're like and
we're gonna put in all this other stuff
and then they're like pastor be ran out
of time um every time a star wars game
gets announced it isn't a narrative
driven RPG I am incredibly disappointed
and think they are wasting their time
okay so you're a big force unleashed
there are exceptions 10 free hahaha that
is true hmm absolutely yeah she kind of
feels like genocide really do you think
that was something that happened because
it was Star Wars maybe because so many
people love Star Wars so more people
probably bought battlefront that
probably wouldn't play team shooters
it's funny though because all of the
beautiful stuff in it what is that were
they kept using in their marketing
photogrammetry ridiculous but all of the
assets are just taken from existing
assets so it's like what you do really
like I don't think it's a bad game yeah
and then we had like six months before
DLC and everyone what the season pass
was just waiting sadly for things to
actually come out and so is there is
there a way to fix battlefront 12 like
if there was an update that could come
out now then you would I am so ready for
the x-wing VR experience oh no
incredible there are two Star Wars VR
experiences that I know of right now one
of them has you repaired the Millennium
Falcon and there's a little bit of
lightsaber combat which in VR is cool as
hell because you're using like a vibe or
an oculus controller and just sort of
tilting it well the lightsaber makes
noises every single time you move it
feels amazing the other one is you're
sitting inside this x-wing you can like
look around in the cockpit and its
really really small but it's just it's
Star Wars is almost perfect for VR and I
would love to see way more of that mmm
hmm that is a hard group design for
between four and forty I mean how he
can't make a good game that's going to
appeal to everyone there now listen like
Annie a kind of thing now you know with
the dead space 3 they were like we'll
make it less scary so more people will
play it not just made everyone who loved
dead space really angry yeah same the
Star Wars no I'd like a game I can play
look they gave oh wait for I say this is
a pledge so yeah I'm sorry just a
housekeeping if you guys want to ask
questions there are mics on the side
it's gonna be easier for us so you up if
you want um we're gonna keep coming and
talking um I like the idea of four x
star wars but I don't think it's ever
been done well because that's not the
stuff that gets explored in the fiction
in the married yes that was it's about
exploration it's a little like the
universe is known the bounds of it a
pretty much set but I know what you mean
yeah yeah yeah I'm like I'm just a
tabletop game which was based off an old
pc game rebellion is amazing yeah so
good go buy it now like well after the
panel after the panel go by it's awesome
please don't leave I'm so much living
here sorry I was just gonna say on for
expert you then just said rebellion
rebellion was a really good basically
for X if you took away the space combat
no but then he just loves ya we agree
great Robin I just wanted to say
something about force unleashed which
was I like the ps2 version what better I
don't know if anyone played it on the
ps2 but even mother was a PSP version
there was more content in that game real
you had more levels more costumes way
more story and cutscenes it was
basically just a really shitty looking
platinum
gay that didn't have quite as much
intriguing combat as a platinum game I
don't think anyone really hated the
first one the first no I remember that
coming out and yeah I mean I played it
on the pc which might be my first
problem like the first one like after
the ps2 and it was alright but I felt
like I could feel the less content after
playing the ps2 version first which was
really weird cuz usually like in that
era the one that was on the older
console was the one that had less in it
but it was the reverse for force
unleashed one I was just always found
out really interesting to it was some
kind of deal some kind of exclusivity
deal with PlayStation yeah probably it
happens tariffs you too is the game that
I got right towards the end and then
realize that life was too short to
bother finishing this game but I really
probably only had about 10 minutes to go
and I was like yeah now we're done it
was that wildly disappointing from what
could have been a very promising go how
long was it from the end you're like a
half hour in you realize you would taper
this with you yes yeah just on a person
that connect game though guys oh yeah oh
yeah what I'm doing oh no it's fine
we're gonna do this now could we get
number four please we're gonna make you
watch all of this I know we're doing no
not her
Oh
Oh
ha
oh sorry
so star wars kinect was a thing oh boy
I'm just a just a funny little thing um
when I started a game spot when we're
making videos we do lower thirds with
people's names l template is that and I
hear that song every time I make a lower
third for someone and it is I see it
every day it's if the haunts my dreams
that clever console so that one's there
it also the worst part is whoever's
dancing isn't very good at it he's wait
stop letting up and I'm just like oh I
could do this better put it on this
better that one's a 55 automatic critic
but my favorite bomb part of this is uh
the top review is an 80 and it says to
anyone expecting a poor dansgame yes
there is dancing oh that one I think my
favorite part of that is paying Jason
Derulo to use that song and changing the
lyrics like imagine me the person who
wrote that like that's on his
reservation resume it's like the bad
ideas just highlighted in yellow
highlight oh yeah who is it that uh
wrote faites bet um Oh Chris o.m.g
figures yeah that's a really good song
yeah IG 88 songs really good to it she's
one of us I don't have an answer for you
I'm sorry I get kinda has a place in my
heart because it's so ridiculous but
it's such a dumb idea oh it's incredible
so here we've got this amazing kind of
world of Star Wars how about we find out
with the Han Solo can dance a lot like
it it's such a nutty idea that I feel
like you probably probably wouldn't
happen now now that Disney's got Star
Wars I don't think you're ever gonna see
a dancing game with like Ray in it I
never say never met I mean I are gonna
thought it to ye
yeah it's just so strange of course I'm
just started wondering Solar wouldn't
dance like that so I'm wondering what he
did what he did I feel like he got to be
like an editable konnagar right cuz he's
too cool to dance he just wrote a club
yeah White's he waits for everyone to
come dance with him and then he's like
all right let's get spotty go like the
kinda guys are totally land oh yeah well
I picked Lando dances I think land o %
definitely I think Han Solo Saturday
Night Fever I think he's real yeah I'm
going the other way men he cannot dance
what I'm saying yeah it's a Carbonite
injury he can't do it anymore um we have
obviously missed some very bad games so
we would love to hear what your least
favorite Star Wars games are if you want
to shout some out the Phantom n is tie
and the one that was on pc I'll fight
you on that because it's amazing i love
that game I don't know what that is
really nice typical Adrian you're right
um on my laptop at home in my room and I
thought it was the best you are a calf
injury you you have a bad opinions I
could see them no I didn't oh yeah it's
it's it's foolish cuz they're all tied
to a very do they let you review against
four games book No thank God if I would
give everything a 10 everybody would be
amazing hi this isn't one of my least
favorite game is actually a game that
was very close to me and I would like to
hear you all talk about Star Wars
Galaxies oh good call yeah um do what
you're playing Star Wars Galaxies for a
little bit yeah I didn't pre or post the
massive yeah yeah um so before the big
change it was epic like had weird
systems you could dance to heal people
there were three deep like that tracks
oh good point
it's over um um yeah it had it was
probably one of the greatest most
involved MMOs and I think because of
that it was its own yeah worst enemy it
was just too much to do but then with
the opposite direction and they created
a world of warcraft with bookies um yeah
yeah I'd love to see it done right and I
don't think necessarily match the old
republic is it I want you know bottom
Star Wars properly but yeah I mean
that's actually really good question
what would your all of your ideal Star
Wars games be um I know what mine is
yeah well alrighty yeah heads up for we
remake of x-wing okay we're done here
thanks guys I feel like nobody don't
Star Wars could be pretty rad yeah that
would be bad medicine that's exactly my
perfect game it plays a smuggler and
you're not a Jedi nothing important and
it's it's I mean it's easy to say Mass
Effect Star Wars that's like cheating
but I feel like something darker like if
it were more the line you have a really
like aliens don't you I really like it
yes all those aliens I kissed in Mass
Effect hahaha uh I'm not sure whether
this is actually the worst star wars
game but the clone wars game because I
played it for like three weeks without a
memory card so I just have to keep
playing the same two levels over and
over again don't want that bad look I
don't want to say you did that to
yourself yeah good if you feel does
anyone remember super bomb bed racing
for the whole story
yeah the worst kart racer ever on the
ps2 I will say there is a worse Star
Wars racing game and it's was it Star
Wars demolition what's what's that was
in which demolition derby with Star Wars
yeah makes it right yeah it was just I
don't know why it existed was it in
space or was it like on the ground like
bracing yeah and I think so yeah you
know I took the old republic to one of
the few games that you can actually
review the cutscenes after you unlock
them and if you play through the light
side and you play through dark side the
ending was exactly the same the planet
blew up no matter whether you choose
life over dykes okay they never finish
the game I know I really annoyed me I'm
that spoilers by the way guys um it is a
bioware game yeah I was gonna say Mass
Effect 3 anyone there's still a lot to
forgive about the coat or games they are
very good they are and that would be my
ideal one who's number three so I just
want to say first I will fight you on
Star Wars demolition because that game
was awesome you could unlock the r
answer and the cloud car and it was this
fight we're gonna fight you could eat
people with the rent you literally eight
people playing here you could place a
rancor yeah okay that's actually really
cool i guess i won't agree with you it
was even so okay so pick you up my ideal
game is now remaking Star Wars
demolition yeah it was all me like
rankle they are that's what I wanted ah
that sounds like motion sickness waiting
to happen I've never played a better
demolition game then start with them
city and they want you to play it was a
big play um anyway USA my other option
my other thing was uh my ideal like star
wars game this might exist and I just
don't know about it but like a star wars
Musso game like dynasty warriors I think
would be really interesting because I
feel like that's basically what the Star
Wars movies are in like big battles it's
like Luke cutting down like 50 bajillion
start like that's the day yeah I see all
the originals not I guess it's more of
like a new thing yeah and that's and
that's what I needs the prequels fail is
because everyone's so powerful and
there's this so remaining so many lasers
and because it
yeah I'm gonna say this right now you
use the force for knowledge and defense
and not attack right you oughta said
that right Yoda said that I just want to
point out sorry Star Wars demolition
actually had a back story about the
Empire officially bands Jabba's
podracers so whoever decides to create a
more life-threatening contest also also
when Galactic legal codes that was
really strange all the time I just
wanted to mention when you're picking a
car in that game in solar demolition the
voice that when you pick a car is way
too seductive like it's free police
abducted or you can get an impression no
rancor yes I don't have your dream car
so you can play this I played it on the
ps1 okay but I mean this appear a
console say we're not here to do that we
just we just go ahead ah ok thank you I
remember being a bit off bait when it
first came out for ps2 but somewhat
everyone think of bounty hunter like the
standalone guy thought that game was
very funny I thought it was doing it but
I enjoyed it when I play I think you can
get it on ps4 actually good I think it's
available for down here soon yeah yeah
um and it hasn't aged great no tell
something great but I didn't hate that
guy I didn't hate it so that was good
being able to like lock on to two
separate targets without controls is the
coolest thing I've ever known species
like playing as a bounty hunter like I
think that's really rad my bike on
Avenida de toi gave it away yes yeah but
also what did you guys think did you
hear about the cancelled from earlier
the death the cancelled Darth Maul game
do you think they would have really
messed that up or I guess it depends on
who would have made it no idea yeah
that's a shame I wasn't cool I'm so
pretty yeah yeah isn't Dolph more like a
scorpion new while
yeah is that Kevin I didn't get his
Canada now yes rebels yes so it is
technically kind of spoilers again sorry
sorry sorry yeah nice hey yeah but yeah
betas Luke's dad this isn't so much a
bad game but what did you think about
galactic battlefront the age of empires
Oh Roy angry I never had age of empires
2 I went straight from age of empires
one to this so for me it was great and I
went back to age of empires 2 and I'm
like where's flying units age of empires
like yeah yeah what do you think it was
like hated it I look I didn't like age
of empires to begin with so look that's
my bad opinion uh what is it yeah I know
yeah but it just didn't feel like Star
Wars it just felt like you know units
packing and that's nothing that I
associate with Star Wars so just didn't
feel right unit stacking yes what about
their other attempts at RTS like empire
at war yeah boss commander the whole
kind of build up your base and then send
swarms of dudes in it doesn't say Star
Wars to me like doesn't mean those games
a bad bone I could do something like
Dawn of War to where it's squad-based
small units or I just feel like that's
such an easy way to make a star wars
game is to have starcraft and reskin it
like obviously that would be great but
it it isn't what a lot of people want
from a star wars game shard it it sell
and it could work but it's easy simple
doesn't require that well building bat
and what people really love about Star
Wars yeah it's not touching on what
makes Star Wars unique or interesting
it's just putting a Star Wars skin on it
yeah like it's a thing that people come
back to a lot but the idea that the star
wars universe is so different to the
trek universe because it feels lived-in
it feels old it feels aged and damaged
and something that's been around um and
the idea of putting your buildings on a
map doesn't seem to jive with that for
me okay I become
Jesus holy I the mode for its hours mud
yeah yeah it's pretty good but again you
yeah and mod makers will always make the
yeah yeah you did it with most things
like the guy who said dynasty warriors
before I feel like that would even work
really well there's a remember if it's
actually dynasty warriors but there's
basically a game like that that's Gundam
in space and it's the coolest thing in
the world but it's still you could do
that to Star Wars but you could also do
the lost of us to stop right so like you
want something character-driven yeah
totally understand yes they are doing
that but we don't really know much about
it yet just over here I'll just did
anyone play Jedi power battles because I
played that on the original console and
then not only one myself tried it on a
pc emulator and it was just as janky
shocking yeah one thing I remember when
I was a kid was on the pc there was a
game called droid works it was a game
based on all the truths from the Star
Wars universe and it was really strange
and really clunky um does anyone
remember that was the one where you
built droids out of different pi think i
had that at school I think that was not
be seen my primary school you see I
actually had the physical play set that
it was kind of inspired by this weird
Brown lump of extruded plastic with
random droid parts that didn't go
together very well pretty much also
describes the game yeah but seriously
there are so many goddamn star wars
games I didn't even realize yeah yes yo
honey yeah the old republic public yes
um oh yeah mmm oh yeah mmm i think that
again I just wanted that to be more of a
single player experience in an MMO but
so fine levels of so were great I
thought
would you like to UM come down and talk
about wake up really here yes sunday
afternoon it packs um again it's my
problem and this is my problem with I
guess the prequels totally I don't like
swarms of Jedi it seems wrong yeah
totally there shouldn't be like armies
of them running around waving their life
savers be like yeah that's not what Jen
I do you know and it's one of the big
things with T a few is that we're saying
before when when Luke can you know use
the Force to grab his lightsaber that's
really exciting when a gel would have
jenna is tearing a Star Destroyer out of
the sky that's just too milky twisting
boring it's how did you guys ever lose
seriously yeah I've never played this
game but have you guys played republic
commandos yeah prolly commander just
want you to know that the guy behind got
it not about you I've got it on my xbox
original i still haven't played it sir
it's great come but it hasn't aged
terribly well but i think that's a thing
with old shooters in general and console
have to have an aged very well does it
look as good as star wars obi wan did
when we saw before yeah speaking of
those games where you just like the
front-flipping Jedi as you're always a
front-flipping job I don't want you guys
are complaining about that I think it's
cool as [ __ ] cuz the Yoda fight scene is
the worst thing to ever happen to Star
Wars is why flips are rad you reckon
you're gonna get a worst thing to happen
on stoles yet the worst the worst oh I
don't know man this is podracing is
pretty bad fortune are you an angel
that's pretty bad how do you feel about
sand sorry should had you thought you're
not like sand
yeah yeah all right so it's all well and
good to sit here and just hate on Star
Wars games sure what in the thought in
which is fun drinking my weight is lunch
break good askin thanks but let why not
talk about like some of the positive
some like some of the games that make us
feel really good cuz we all love Star
Wars my way yeah yeah absolutely so why
not break down what we love about some
of these games and then create our
perfect star wars game from it well I'm
a massive tabletop game as well as a
video gamer and fancy flights current
range of Star Wars games is incredible
like x-wing models dog fights better
than any other board game ever played
are martyrs great the card game is just
like the last bastion of the EMU that's
great imperial the marvelous imperial
assault is perfect because it's like a
campaign based small squad of characters
Imperial it's not the one with all the
figures yeah they're amazing as well I
wish they were scaled they're not but
that God they look good um so yeah
absolutely good Star Wars games out
there but they're also just don't I'm
really excited about the Star Wars games
that he have to come out I think there
are three souls games in development
right now or two maybe that from what i
know are gonna be amazing so we're
headed in the right direction I think
and I think you know if we do get that
Amy heading Styles game salt just under
percent but something that I think we're
all touching on is we want a single
player campaign yes yeah story yeah we
don't want multiplayer we don't want I
think the reason they haven't done that
is because it's harder you know and it's
if you screw up the story in a star wars
game people will hate you more than they
would hate a multiplayer game being bad
that's a lot of pressure yes iron girl I
remastered recently and I've been
playing it for like the end of time what
are they skin Star Wars into skyrim oh
ho okay mods people have done that yeah
been like you know instead of modding
Skyrim to Star Wars but built like from
scratch a star wall Skyrim open war game
with the whole character progression lpg
i think that kind of thing would be
almost exactly what we're all [ __ ] a
pretty good parallel tailored story that
we'd like but yeah i would play the hell
out of that kind of star wars going
without doubt one that lets you play
anything a smuggler or a general totally
but that said I think you could put
pretty much all of my favorite
properties and put them in the sky room
and I would be happy like if you could
put pokemon in that yeah yeah yeah yeah
I'm just dumb we were talking about the
positives and one of the positives for
me was tie fighter was but one of the
best pc games if sequel x-wing
especially when it went to it didn't
followed the movies but also went to
that expanded universe like Grand
Admiral for and came into it as well
that was the first time I saw grant will
fawn and then all this books there
follow this on 20 i still play this game
on dosbox and it's fantastic it still
holds up it's still it's you know a bit
clunky but it's still beautiful why
wouldn't developed as kind of go back to
that go that pc flight sim kind of look
for I think that's gonna happen in VR
like I imagine that someone is probably
working on that I mean even arcade games
have done really good jobs that I heard
what it's called but the arcade normal
is it and I don't remember the name of
it but it it's just you flying through
the Death Star and it looks really nice
elbows okay I'm pretty sure that's or so
is that good yeah yeah yeah it's just
okay yeah it's really really good and
it's like I think that you just need
racing sims especially if we're gonna
have it as technically accurate a Star
Wars is kind of niche it's Star Wars so
it's huge but I feel like putting it in
VR is the perfect way to continue that
and I feel like someone's going to be
doing it official one of the great
memories of Title I was remembering all
the cool every keyboard button was an
actual thing to do like River shields
and I was there is fantastic so do yeah
yeah so that was a Empire Strikes Back
of Atari who he was played empire
strikes back on Atari yeah just a lot of
people that's crazy yeah oh it's mostly
wondering what your opinion was because
since it's no longer lucasarts doing the
games it's gonna be EA and they're just
farming it out oh you're
p on EA's general approach to dlc for
everything like battlefront sir key
point like that's how they make money
for the most part yeah that's a thing
sorry y-you really positively sure yeah
well um it still depends on the studio I
mean the biggest thing with you that you
have to remember is that they are I
think still the highest grossing
publisher which means that they have
stakeholders who demand things of them
so that's why you know I mentioned dead
space 3 not being scary before that
probably wasn't a developer decision
that would have been a stakeholder
decision we want to sell more units and
I think they also get them really tight
deadlines and EA does that where maybe
they wish they could have put more
content in the game but stakeholders are
like we want this to come out at this
point in time so it has to be DLC and I
I don't want to ever blame developers
for that but it is a thing that EA is
known to do that continues to happen and
people complained about it enough with
battlefront that I'm just hoping that
they take that feedback because I mean
the season pass this thing I think is
just ridiculous people paid a lot of
money and had to wait a really long time
for content not even knowing what it was
like that's just terrible for consumers
and they have noticed so I'm hoping that
it just changes let's just hope that he
gets better
yeah maybe stop buying season passes
people stop doing it also stopped
pre-orders yeah all right I thought it'd
come up for star wars old republic I
personally really like it because it has
both aspects of single-player and also
groups so they have the heroics and
everything that you can do and events
that you can play as a group or a guild
because I have a team we're on Team
speakers so we have a lot of fun
interacting with each other but then if
we can't get on at the same time we also
have class missions so we do a lot of
single play as well yeah and so I think
they've done a great job of intertwining
the two yeah I feel like that's one of
the better received souls games and I
really like it but are you still playing
it yeah how many people are still
playing swindle you know what I we did
lose sound like even your team is cut
down by about 10 people but they're
gonna come back because the expansions
coming back so I hope they play it
through and then another expansion comes
out and then they'll be coming back and
we'll team up in the big event yeah it
just I feel like it died off pretty
quickly because I well as someone who
mentioned before it was good at the
start but then well a lot of people
didn't like the single player so Louis
you said he's engineer at Dell and he
left the game because he doesn't like
the single player so it's kind of hard
to meet both hmm you know aspects but I
think they've done a fabulous job and I
really like it yeah I think it visually
you totally it feels very very good it
feels like Star Wars I just wasn't a
huge fan of the actual mechanics of
gameplay to a degree they've got great
storylines what I do my car yes
absolutely it is also really good for
accommodating social situations I think
that's a much better social game than
battlefront is 107 yeah yeah and I think
it's something you think that's worth
remembering our star wars we keep
talking about you know a single player
experience but star wars in terms of the
films is about groups hanging out but
yeah absolutely tona and that's
something that a lot of Star Wars games
don't do they don't give you a small
group yeah so I think that's where
galaxies the galaxies um Old Republic
really worked well yeah hey guys look
I'm just here to name-check Rogue
Squadron obviously from that obviously
the best action scenes in star wars are
the Starfighter battles and some of the
best games obviously the best I'll the
staff at a game so x-wing TIE fighter x
and Rogue Squadron do you think that
this this fantasy of the Jedi and the
fact that we all kind of want to be
Jedi's is kind of like the underlying
problem of Star Wars games is the Jedi
facts you ruined I would be sick I don't
have stock Jedi I don't think we all
want to be shown on a wedge like I
always wanted to be Han Solo man that
dude was wicked cool heiko I got bounty
hunter arakune mmm daddy how that stash
smuggler yeah yeah yeah and I now do you
think that that's one of the big
problems as they focus on Jedi and they
don't focus on the rest all the other
cool [ __ ] they're gone I mean like who's
super super excited for rogue one yes
right awesome I'm and again because it's
focusing on the other parts of the
universe it's not making the whole I
think he's like force sensitive I don't
know if he's a Jedi I mean yeah not
gonna be for me either you know well
yeah yeah yes that was work that coming
adults always the exception right if you
can be Darth be Darth but one of my
favorite parts of Jedi Academy was that
you could avoid murdering people by mind
checking your way past or pulling the
weapon out of their hand and so they're
taking the MMO other gun you have any
recommendations for games like that
since then it's not totally similar but
my fatal dishonored is a very good exam
I game it does that is the witcher 2
actually pretty much every single
interaction in that game you can talk
someone out of fighting you so it also
has this fork at very early on in the
game where it just completely changes
two totally different stories you can
play it through a bunch of different
times but almost every single boss fight
you can be like hey I don't actually
want to fight you and tell people out of
it you have to be really careful with
your dialogue decisions but it's not a
skill tree based thing like mass effect
we have to have like high charisma or
anything which it too is a very good
game should definitely play that no 47
we got time for one more I think this is
a bit of a can of worms but you were
talking about how you have the
battlefront experience you've got the
tour experience one is very the groups
and not a very trained transient whereas
the tour is by its nature you establish
a guild and you play with the same
people over and over have we lost
something in moving multiplayer
away from dedicated servers which kind
of foster the communities yeah yes
immediately looking David for that one
yeah absolutely i'm dedicated servers
are just a great for you have a server
with a set of server rules you can
control who comes in comes in comes out
you have an admin who can kick out
idiots you can foster the right color
community that you want yeah i think
that's very very important absolutely
yeah okay but there's also examples of i
know i was playing left 4 dead one and
when left the dead two came out and just
completely split the community they
should have just added the maps to
leopard at one which meant that you know
though people playing both games
separately and it's we have a lot of
style homes games so they've already
divided people who likes tall was a
million times at that point anyway it's
just so many and none of them seem to
cater to many of us entirely hmm true
anymore final questions okay i'd like to
thank everyone who was up here we have
no conclusion sorry we didn't get at it
um we don't know any dog and a coalition
and also the demolition remake
demolition right now this is really cool
though thank you every thank you guys
you